새벽의 남자 김단태 왔습니다.
오늘은 좀 주식시장이 수수께끼 같은 상승을 하고 있어요.
이 상승이 완전히 납득이 가진 않습니다.
왜 납득이 가지 않는지는 조금 뒤에서 얘기를 해보고
현재는 나스닥이 1.2% 상승하고 있어요.
상승 자체는 되게 기분이 좋은 일이긴 합니다.
다우지수 0.2% 하락했고
S&P500 0.6% 상승했어요.
러셀 2000지수는 크게 변화가 없었습니다.
주요 종목들 히트맵을 보면
대형주 위주의 상승이 있었음을 한 번에 알 수가 있죠.
그래서 엔비디아나 테슬라, 구글, 메타, 아마존
거의 빅테크 종목들이 상승을 이끌어서 지수가 올랐고
엄밀히 보면 대부분의 종목들은 오히려 하락을 했습니다.
약간은 건전하지 않다라고 느낄 수도 있는 그런 상승인 것 같고요.
그런데 왜 상승이 수수께끼 같냐라고 물으신다면
오늘 발표한 생산자 물가 지수에 있습니다.
생산자 물가 지수가 지금 표를 보셔도 아시겠지만
예상치보다 훨씬 더 높게 나왔어요.
그냥 높게 나온 정도가 아니라
생산자 물가 지수가 예상치가 0.5% 상승이었는데
1.4% 상승.
그러니까 틀린 정도가 그냥 조금 틀린 게 아니라
거의 3배? 이렇게 틀리게 나오는 거죠.
전체 생산자 물가 지수도 그렇고
근원 생산자 물가 지수라고 해서
음식과 에너지를 제외한
찐 생산자 물가 지수라고 할 수 있는 이 지수조차
예상치의 3배가 넘게 나왔다.
이런 것들이 상당히 기분이 나쁜 거죠.
이 정도 지표면 사실은 시장이 반응을 했어야 하는데
흥미롭게도 시장은 오히려 상승을 하는 거죠.
처음엔 물론 좀 쇼크의 어떤 흐름은 있었는데
꾸준히 올랐다. 이렇게 볼 수가 있습니다.
자, 더욱더 기분이 나쁜 이유는 뭐냐면
생산자 물가 지수는 보통 두 달 뒤에
소비자 물가 지수로 전가가 되는 경향이 있다라는 거예요.
이거 너무 상식적으로 생각해도 이해가 되죠.
생산자 물가 지수라는 건
생산자 입장에서의 물가고
내가 중국집을 하는데
밀의 가격이 오르면
짜장면의 가격이 오를 수밖에 없지 않겠습니까?
이 밀의 가격이 생산자 물가 지수
짜장면의 가격이 소비자 물가 지수니까요.
그래서 이 두 달간의 차이가 있을 수밖에 없고
이걸 이제 차트로 그린 건데
이번에 생산자 물가 지수가 이렇게 튀었으니까
결국에 두 달 뒤에 소비자 물가 지수도
매우 올라갈 가능성이 있어 보인다.
그리고 이걸 시장에서 상당히 불편해할 수가 있겠죠.
그래서 양영빈 기자님께서도 비슷한 류의 말을 하셨어요.
그래서 PPI가 전년 대비해서 6% 상승을 했는데
이렇게 6%까지 상승한 게 매우 드뭅니다.
그래서 코로나 이후에 미칠 듯한 인플레이션 장에서
한번 PPI가 올랐었긴 했었는데
어쨌든 그래서 이렇게 2022년 이후에
PPI가 전년 대비 6%나 상승하는
생산자 물가 지수가 예상보다 이렇게 훨씬 높게 나오는
상승한 게 매우 드뭅니다.
이런 상황이라면 원래 주식이 약세여야 하는데
그런데 주식은 오르고 있어요.
특히 엔비디아, 테슬라, 애플 같은 초대형 기술주가 시장을 끌어올렸어요.
그런데 예외적인 부분들도 있는 것 같아요.
그러니까 엔비디아, 테슬라, 애플 전부 미중 정상회담에서
트럼프랑 같이 중국으로 갔거든요.
그러니까 이 회사들은 뭔가 중국과의 큰 딜을 할 수도 있겠다.
왜냐하면 보통 정상회담 하면 뭔가 큰 딜, 깜짝 발표 이런 게 있습니다.
다들 중국과의 관계를,
관계가 되게 중요한 회사들이거든요.
그래서 이런 회사들이 뭔가 큰 발표를 할 수도 있을 거다라는
기대 때문에 오르는 부분도 있어요.
이제 예레들만 올라도 사실 시가총액에 상당히 많은 부분을 차지하기 때문에
지수 전체가 오를 수가 있는 거죠.
좀 특별한 부분은 있다.
미중 정상회담에 대한 기대감이 녹여들어갔다라고 볼 수가 있겠죠.
물론 그것뿐만 아니겠죠.
이 AI 관련된 주식들이고 현재 미국의 주가지수를 가장 많이 포함돼 있는 게
미국의 AI 주식인데,
AI 주식 아시겠지만 너무 당연한 얘기죠.
기업의 실적, 데이터 센터, 투자, 생산성, 혁명 이런 것들을 시장에서 보고 있기 때문에
이런 상승이 있었다고 볼 수도 있는 거고
그러니까 시장이 지금 금리를 더 봐야 되느냐, 물가를 봐야 되느냐,
아니야, 실적을 봐야 된다.
이 사이에서 시장도 왔다 갔다 하고 있는 그런 상황이라고 이해를 하면 될 것 같습니다.
그래서 투자자들이 더 실적에 집중하는 날은 이런 AI 주식들이 오르는 거고
금리에 더 집중하는 날은 원자재가 오르거나,
아니면 이제 주식은 좀 힘을 못 쓰는 그런 장이 있는 거고요.
자, 그래서 어제 같은 경우가 상당히 흥미로운데
어제가 시장이 물가를 좀 열심히 봤었어요, 맨 처음에.
그래서 어제 CPI가 나오자마자 미장이 많이 빠졌었는데
처음에 많이 빠지다가 하락을 꽤 많이 회복하면서 미장이 끝났거든요.
근데 이 하락을 어떻게 회복을 했는지를 봤더니
어제, 어제에 하락을 많이 하다가 SOXL이라는 미국의 반도체 ETF거든요.
세배레버리지 반도체 ETF에 역대급 자금이 들어왔습니다.
그래서 저가매수 자금이 많이 유입이 됐다라는 거죠.
어제도 시장이 실적을 볼까, 물가를 볼까.
어제의 미장의 경우도 처음에는 시장이 물가를 보다가
어, 생각해보니까 좀 싼데 하면서 실적을 보고 들어온 자금들이 있었다라는 거고
그런 흐름이 오늘도 좀 이어진다라는 거죠.
자, 하지만 문제는 채권시장은 또 다른데요.
다른 얘기를 하고 있다라는 겁니다.
채권시장은 현재 상당히 긴장하고 있고 무서워하고 있습니다.
자, 어떻게 무서워하고 있을까요?
바로 금리에서 나타나는데
자, 4월 CPI를 발표하자마자 채권금리가 이렇게 올랐고요.
채권금리가 이제 오른 상태에서 결국에는 4월 PPI, 생산자 물가지수가 나오자마자
이제 결국에 거의 4.5까지 왔어요.
그러니까 어저께는 4.44, 4.45 이 정도에서 왔다 갔다 했다면
이제는 4.5 근처입니다.
4.5 근처까지 더 십 년물 미국의 채권금리가 올라갔고
이것은 다시 말해서 물가에 대한 우려가 있다라는 그런 얘기겠죠.
그래서 결국에 우리가 물가가 우려가 되면 너무나도 당연한 얘기겠지만
이란 전쟁과 관련된 걸 또 지켜볼 수밖에 없다.
이런 말씀을 드리고 싶고
아직까지 소비자 가격으로는 완전히 넘어가진 않았는데
결국에 아, 이 PPI를 봤을 때는 CPI도 당분간 정말 힘들 수 있겠다.
하지만 또 시장은 또 그 다음의 미래를 보는 거일 수도 있는 거 같아요.
호르몬즈 이후에서부터는 정말 힘들 수 있겠다.
어쨌든 미중 정상회담 이제 본격적으로 회담을 가질 예정이기 때문에
어떤 얘기가 나올 건지 한번 좀 지켜볼 필요는 있을 것 같고요.
자, 2017년 정상회담 트럼프 1기 때도 한번 중국이 갔었는데요.
이때는 보잉이나 퀄컴, GE 이런 것들이 큰 계약을 발표를 했었습니다.
다만 결과적으로 이런 질들이 흐지부지 되는 경향들도 있었기 때문에
단기적으로 시장이 이걸 좋아할 수도 있겠지만
실적으로 연결이 안 될 수도 있다라는 거
여러분들도 한번 그냥 뭐랄까 쇼하는 걸 수도 있다라는
과거에는 그랬다라는 걸 우리가 머릿속에 한번 넣어 놓을 필요는 있겠죠.
자, 그리고 뭐 AI 관련된 주식들 여전히 또 좋을 수밖에 없는 게
계속 이 GPU 렌탈 가격이라고 하죠.
GPU를 빌려서 이제 이용을 하는 경우가 많은데
GPU에 대한 수요가 많으면 많을수록 GPU의 렌탈 가격 계속 오르고 있습니다.
그래서 역대 최고치를 갱신하고 있다라는 말씀.
AI 이상 없는 것 같아.
AI 관련된 지표만 봤을 땐 사실 너무 좋아요.
근데 현재 이
지정학 그리고 매크로 이슈에 얼마나 버틸 수 있을지
이런 게 이제 중요한 포인트겠죠.
어쨌든 근데 AI 그냥 제3자의 관점에서 지표를 봤을 때는 크게 이상은 없어 보인다라는 말을 하면서
제가 요즘에 쇼츠도 하고 있으니까
쇼츠가 좀 더 영상을 많이 많이 올릴 것 같거든요.
그러니까 구독을 꼭 해 주셔야 쇼츠도 볼 수 있다라는 말씀 드리면서
저는 또 돌아오도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.